(lively guitar strumming)
- [Announcer] Dead Kevin.
(laughing)
- Ah, this is a great birthday.
- Hey man, happy birthday.
- Yeah, happy birthday, man.
- Hey, check this out.
Hold on.
- Ever do this?
- Yeah.
- Happy birthday, Ahmed!
(laughing)
- How do you that that?
That's awesome.
I wanna try it.
- Oh my god, this is
brilliant! (laughing)
- I represent the lollipop kids.
(laughing)
- Ahmed, that's too much.
That's probably too much.
- [Jack] Slow down, Ahmed.
- Ahmed.
- Ahmed, slow down.
- Ahmed, that's enough.
- Slow down.
(loud thud)
(screaming)
- What happened?
What happened?
- Ahmed!
- Should I call somebody?
Should I call somebody?
- Call 9-1-1!
- Oh god!
- Calling them,
I'm calling them!
(screaming)
I am!
- He's dying!
- Hello?!
- This is the worst
birthday ever!
- Hello?!
Hello, yes my friend fell down!
It was his birthday
and he fell down!
Oh god, there's
blood everywhere!
Blood out of his head!
(screaming)
- Why?!
- No, my friend!
Not my dad!
- Tell them I'm
freaking out right now!
I am freaking out!
- No, I'm 27!
I'm a 27 year old man!
- Jesus Christ!
- But is this off the record?!
We were doing helium!
- And tell him he's
like the nicest guy!
- We were doing helium
for my friend's birthday!
- Tell him he's dying!
- I didn't enjoy it at all!
(high-pitched screaming)
(group screaming)
(guitar strumming)
- Hey, huffing helium's
no laughing matter,
as funny as that sketch was.
It's a dangerous--
- (moans) Ow!
Tell us about your
craziest birthday story
in our comment section and
subscribe to our channel,
DeadKevinSketch.
Stay off of helium, kids.
Give me some of that ganji!